diesen hawking einer der bekanntesten
physiker der welt schlägt alarm er meint
dass wir die welt so schnell wie möglich
verlassen müssen die ausbreitung in den
weltraum sei das einzige was uns noch
retten können wir müssen bald eine
mondbasis aufbauen und auf dem mars
landen viel zeit bleibe nicht mehr die
zeit drängt also wieso warum weshalb
jetzt bei klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
stephen hawking ist wirklich aller mehr
zitat die erde ist in so vielen
bereichen bedroht dass es für mich
schwierig ist noch positiv zu denken
ich hoffe die großen nationen werden
sich zusammentun um diese
herausforderung für uns alle gemeinsam
zu meistern
das sagte er auf dem samens festival in
trondheim klimawandel hast du ihnen
einschläge epidemien künstliche
intelligenz oder das
bevölkerungswachstum all das worüber wir
hier berichtet haben und wo wir zum teil
panikmache vorgeworfen wurde kann die
erde schon bald unbewohnbar machen er
leugne nicht die wichtigkeit des kampfes
gegen den klimawandel und die
erderwärmung zitat im gegensatz zu
donald trump der gerade die schlimmste
und falsche entscheidung zum klimawandel
getroffen hat die die welt jemals
gesehen hat eines der weiteren probleme
sieht er in den begrenzten ressourcen
zitat wir benötigen mehr raum und der
einzige ort an denen wir gehen könnten
ist der weltraum es ist an der zeit
andere sonnensysteme zu erforschen ich
bin davon überzeugt dass wir die erde
verlassen müssen
ja und das in den nächsten 200 bis 500
jahren also von seinem szenario das die
welt in 100 jahren unter geht da ist der
inzwischen von ab wir hatten ja dauer
berichtet aber dass es immer eine gute
idee ist ein zweites standbein zu haben
dagegen ist ja nichts einzuwenden
deshalb hat hawking die nationen der
welt jetzt aufgerufen in den nächsten 30
jahren eine basis auf dem mond zu bauen
bis zum jahr 2025 also schon in sieben
jahren müssten menschen zum mars fliegen
zitat die ausbreitung im weltraum ist
das einzige was uns noch retten kann
hawking sieht die raumfahrt vor dem
nächsten sprung die besiedlung ferner
planeten sei keine science-fiction mehr
es gibt inzwischen rund 50 exoplaneten
die bewohnbar sein können allerdings ist
die frage wie wir dahin kommen können
das steht mich noch im wahrsten sinne
des wortes in den stern erst wenn wir
den warp antrieb gebaut haben wäre eine
solche reise möglich bis dahin bleibt
nur die besiedlung in unserem
sonnensystem und die scheint immer
realistischer gerade wurden unmengen
wasser auf dem mars gefunden die
lebensgrundlage für die besiedlung nasa
und auch die esa wollen auf den mond wo
gerade offenbar eishöhlen entdeckt
wurden dazu mehr
wie es ist also eine menge in bewegung
und die chancen stehen nicht schlecht
dass wir zunächst auf dem mond und
später auf dem mars permanente stationen
errichten schauen wir mal
und das am besten natürlich hier bei
pixum wenn er kein video zu diesem und
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesslich stehen genau auf die
glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer
über neue videos informiert ansonsten
filtert nämlich der youtube algorithmus
die videos heraus hier also hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken 1000
raketen zum mars da geht es um die pläne
von ihnen masken spacex ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran